we've got an exclusive up close look at
Federal efforts to crack down on the
dangerous and illegal trade of fentanyl
the CDC estimates that more than 68
thousand fatalities from synthetic
opioids were reported in these United
States in the 12 months ending last
August that's a very big number acbs
news crew followed federal agents
yesterday as they raided a suspected
fentanyl lab and Jeff begaze is in
Tucson Arizona where this all went down
Jeff good morning
Tony investigators tell us that about
six months of intelligence LED them to
that house and that Tucson neighborhood
and What They seized there also suggests
to them that the Mexican cartels are
trying to step up efforts to distribute
fentanyl on U.S streets
before the sun came up Homeland Security
agents gathered ready to raid at Tucson
Arizona home starting to roll we were
there as they moved in with the help of
local police to stay on this side of the
mark unit inside they found a hundred
pounds of what they believe are
precursor chemicals or chemicals used to
make fentanyl a drug 50 times more
potent than heroin it's been flooding
cities across the country and blame for
thousands of deaths a year why is it so
hard to stop the distribution because
there's so many different ways that it
can be smuggled into the United States
right it's coming in through 18 wheelers
it's coming in through passenger
vehicles it's coming in through people
walking across the border according to
investigators China is one of the
primary suppliers for these precursor
chemicals for Fentanyl and look what's
written on this box but it's harder to
track because it's being shipped in
smaller amounts how does that pose
problems for law enforcement they're not
going to raise as much suspicion if
they're coming in in in smaller
shipments versus a large bulk shipment
last year law enforcement seized more
than 50 million fentanyl-laced pills and
over ten thousand pounds of fentanyl
powder that's enough to kill every
American I don't believe that they're
doing everything that they can Misty
Little's 26 year old daughter Cheyenne
died after swallowing a pill that she
didn't know was laced with fentanyl I
want people to know that Cheyenne was a
vibrant young woman that had her whole
entire future ahead of her you know one
bad decision she shouldn't have lost her
life over I want people to know that her
life mattered
the Mexican cartels are always trying to
stay one step ahead of U.S law
enforcement and what was found in that
Tucson home and maybe an example of that
investigators are still running tests
but they believed that what was found in
that home may be a fentanyl lab they're
still investigating they see those every
now and then but they don't see those
fentanyl Labs on U.S soil a lot Tony
well you know I've sat with those
families who've lost a loved one I've
been out with paramedics trying to save
lives if this can make a difference it's
a value Valiant effort yeah thank you
very much